[Music]
it's
wow luca that was hard to watch you uh
coming
[Music]
[Applause]
we do not go anywhere near the surface
got it
everything good is above the surface
walking
air the sky clouds the sun
whoa don't look at it just kidding
definitely look at it
have you ever gone to the human town
yeah
i'm kind of an expert
someone got lucky today
hey leave them alone hop on go start the
club
for losers
[Applause]
my name is julia marcovaldo we underdogs
have to look out for each other
what's under the dogs
this is my dad what do you think he
kills with those anything that swims
your life is so much cooler than mine
there's a million things you think you
can't do
all you need is a chance to try
something
[Music]
can you still hear him nope just you
good
now hang on
what's wrong with you stupido you do it
now just say the thing
what's wrong with you stupidoh
[Music]
we can go anywhere do anything
we just gotta stick together we
underdogs have to look out for each
other right
underdogs this is gonna be the best
summer ever
see the whole world together
[Music]
it'll be amazing
but there's just one thing
wait did you see that no one can find
out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where did you boys say you were from
[Music]
you